in her first Network TV interview one of
Jeffrey Epstein's accusers sheds new
light on people she says helped Epstein
run his alleged sex trafficking ring
Sara ransom accuses Epstein of raping
her on his private island and says
Epstein had help from at least two women
who were close to him ransom is featured
in the new documentary series being
released on Netflix Jeffrey Epstein
filthy-rich the documentary also
includes an interview with a contractor
who worked for Epstein for years who
describes what he saw on that Island I
started working on the island in 1999
Steve Scully worked for Jeffrey Epstein
for six years I was there for
maintenance on Jeffrey Epstein's
telecommunications and data equipment in
the Netflix documentary series Jeffrey
Epstein filthy-rich Scully says he
frequented the wealthy financiers 75
acre private island in the Caribbean
little st. James I was on the island
probably a hundred times I was
ultimately in every single building
Scully says he often saw young girls and
prominent guests visit including Prince
Andrew who he says he saw by the pool
with a young girl Scully says the FBI
showed him this photograph of Prince
Andrew with Virginia Roberts gu Frey and
as soon as I saw that was the girl that
he was kind of like grinding against at
the pool she was at that time wearing a
bikini bottom
that's it gu Frey claims she was forced
to have sex with Prince Andrew when she
was 17 the prince has acknowledged a
friendship with Epstein but denies any
sexual contact with GU Frey I have no
recollection of ever meeting this lady
what was the most striking thing that
you found about Epstein I just think
that it is just baffling how he
manipulated and lied his way through his
entire life I'd like to answer that
question
but today I wouldn't have to assert my
Sixth Amendment rights
director Lisa Bryant started working on
the documentary in 2018 before Jeffrey
Epstein's arrest this pyramid scheme it
just the scope was unbelievable I mean
hundreds and hundreds of girls we
learned from the very first day that I
arrived in the island maybe started
Sarah ransom was 22 when she met Epstein
in 2006 the South African who'd come to
New York to study fashion was soon
invited to the island quite soon after
that I was called into his bedroom and
then raped and there was no way of
escaping the island in the documentary
ransom describes being in shock I think
the more he saw you being damaged the
more he enjoyed it the more it excited
him last year after Epstein died by
suicide in prison
ransom joined other survivors in court
what was that day like for you I wanted
to see him hardly comfortable I have a
faith that maybe I'll get another day in
coal way I can face my co-conspirators
the people that helped Jeffrey rape me
every day Epstein's chief lieutenants
says ransom were Gillen Maxwell and
Sarah Kellen you know and Jeffrey wanted
me you know sarah kaelin
or Peggy Lane would call needs his
bedroom and I had no choice but to go
Gillian was always on the phone and
sarah kaelin was always on her laptop
organizing things did Sarah Kellen
essentially make appointments for you
what did she do
absolutely she booked all my flights
Sarah Kellen went on to marry NASCAR
driver Brian Vickers in a statement to
CBS News Kellan spokesperson said
Epstein sexually and psychologically
abused Kellen for years the statement
went on to say Kellen scheduled
appointments for Epstein and Maxwell at
their direction
adding Kellen is aware of the pain and
damage Epstein caused
and deeply regrets that she had any part
in it
Gillan Maxwell denies any involvement
with Epstein's alleged sex trafficking
ring today
Maxwell's whereabouts are unknown
neither woman has been criminally
charged when you read that Gillen
Maxwell says she had no involvement in
this or when Sara kelan says she was a
victim what's your reaction to that I
think it's disgraceful
and these people are gonna burn at home
Gillian knew exactly what she was doing
she knew that every time she called me I
was gonna be raped every time Sara
killing you for every girl that she
organized to go on that island or to be
picked up by a car to go to the New York
mansion she knew that these girls were
there to be raped repeatedly she's gonna
rot in home definitely this never really
goes away does it Sara
no and the fear never goes away
I love everyday in fear I don't know
where these people are I don't know
whether they're gonna knock on my door
whether they gonna phone me whether I'm
gonna get an email it's affected me to
such an extent that until there I said I
don't think I'll ever start to you Sara
ransom settled a lawsuit with Epstein
and with Maxwell in 2018 Virginia gu
Frey also settled a suit with Maxwell
Prince Andrews lawyers told CBS News
they had no comment on Steve Scully's
claim regarding The Prince and Virginia
gue Frey on the island they did offer a
quote from a friend who said Andrew was
on the island at the time with his
age-appropriate girlfriend the full
documentary is out tomorrow on Netflix
and Gail one thing that you sure see in
this documentary is how the women
involved with Jeffrey Epstein are
dealing with long lingering and profound
emotional damage that's what struck me
about the interview with Sara
Anthony is that even though the
perpetrator Jeffrey Epstein is dead that
she still doesn't have peace that she
still doesn't feel she has justice and
to know according to her that women
other women I'll never understand this
how other women could participate in
harming another woman is very very
difficult my heart goes out to her very
powerful interview yeah one of the one
of the I've interviewed several
survivors now and one of the the the
common themes you hear is is they felt
for years they just weren't heard they
they made complaints and and the court
system didn't respond it took very long
the first complaint was made that we
know of was made in 1996 and it wasn't
until last year that that the Jeffrey
Epstein
you know actually appeared in court